hey you guys it's movie retrospective
time
going back to the 1990s for this one uh
had you seen this movie before i'd seen
it before yeah i had seen this before uh
as well so this was probably like the
second or third time yeah i've seen it
third time i've seen it and it's kind of
one of those ones it's weird because i
feel like this is one that
doesn't get brought up a lot when you
talk about the 90s but then when you do
bring it up people are like oh yeah like
that was a really good i feel like it's
a little bit underrated every time i see
it i like it but then i forget that i
see it i forget that i said yeah it's
not weird oh and then i see you guys oh
yeah i remember this one
this is a good one yeah this is uh tales
from the crypt presents demon knight
from 1995. really good mixture of uh
practical effects in cg
yeah i mean you know obviously this came
out in 95 so you know cg was still kind
of in its infancy i feel like they
mostly used cg for kind of the light
effects like lightning and magical
effects the magical type stuff and i
will say that there was like some weird
like green screen in the beginning a
crypt keeper bumper so they could have
the crypt keeper like walking because
normally he wouldn't because he's just a
puppet all the demons and the monsters
are practical though they're real good
real good outfits
it really does and the gore in this is
like really well done i mean considering
this is a fairly low budget movie i
think it costs 13 million
something like that
so the interesting thing about this so
tales from the crypt i mean for
for any youngsters out there
tales from the crypt you know obviously
started out as kind of like ec comics
a long time ago but then
hbo made a series of it uh that i think
started in 89
and it was really successful it ran for
like seven seasons so it ran till 1996
and they would basically take
you know ec comics kind of stuff same
kind of stuff as creep show and things
like that where it's kind of like a
morality tale
but the hbo tales from the crypt series
what they basically wanted to do with
that was just make it fun really gory
really smutty
and just kind of have all these horror
puns and just make it kind of like a
good time
so i was a big fan of the tales from the
crypt show the original one and i think
i've seen pretty much every episode over
the time oh and they had they had like
tons of um
guest stars and stuff too and i think
even people like tom hanks and arnold
schwarzenegger and stuff like directed
some episodes
so they were able to get like some big
names in it so it was kind of like a big
deal so the fact that it was so
successful meant that eventually they
were going to make the leap to movies
now
this movie
uh was actually not intended to be a
tales from the crypto movie at first
matter of fact the screenplay for this
was actually floating around hollywood
uh
since
the 80s since 87 so this even predated
the tales from the crypt series
so originally it was nothing to do with
that
um but what ended up happening was that
it sort of got like passed around to
different direct like i think tom
holland was initially gonna do it he did
uh child play and fright night
and uh then he didn't end up doing it he
ended up working on something else and
then like mary lambert who had done pet
cemetery like she got hold of it she was
gonna do it but then pet cemetery two
tanked and so she couldn't get the
funding and then it kind of cut past
like uh you know charles band had it
like that cheapy full moon pictures
thing that he has but then joel silver's
production company got hold of it and
they were kind of like okay well
universal pictures have been talking
about doing a trilogy
of movies inspired by tales from the
crypt
this was originally supposed to be the
second one i think they had two other
ones that were kind of in it wasn't a
production but they had them planned one
was called dead easy
which was supposed to be like a zombie
uh you know new orleans type thing
and the other one was called body count
now it's funny because if you watch
demon knight at the very end like if you
there's a post credits sequence where
the crypt keeper pops up and says you
know stay tuned for the next movie which
is dead easy but they never did make it
so there was technically a trilogy demon
knight being the first one the second
one was bordello of blood which was okay
that was the one with dennis miller
sorry um and there actually was a third
one called ritual which was kind of like
a zombie new orleans type of thing but
that was only released uh direct to
video at least in this country i think
like never seen i think in the
philippines and [ __ ] like it went
they'd show to the theaters but it was a
it had like um tim curry was in it
jennifer gray was in it craig sheffer
was in it was it any good no okay
i wanted it to be good yeah uh that came
out in 2002. so there were technically
three it just wasn't the ones that
these i mean this one was supposed to be
the second one but because it was the
most ec like they they decided to do
this one first
and then you know so it didn't but the
weird thing about this like i said this
isn't based on an ec comic story it's
not even really a morality tale type
story like a lot of the tales from the
crypt stuff was because as i said this
wasn't really intended to be a tales
from the crew story they just liked it
so much and decided to do it
so the guy that ended up directing this
i knew his name sounded familiar his
name's ernest dickerson now prior to
this he had done that movie juice with
tupac do you remember that that was in
uh yeah that was 92. yeah and um so i
guess he got this gig on that but since
then he hasn't done a [ __ ] ton of movies
but he's done like a [ __ ] ton of like
really good tv he did like some walking
dead he did the wire dexter house of
cards man in the high castle like he's
directed episodes of all sorts of [ __ ]
like that
um so he directed this movie and i have
to say
i really this is almost kind of like
a siege type movie i mean it goes into
that you know what i mean because at
first you know it starts it's like a car
chase and everything like that but
pretty soon everybody's kind of like
trapped in one location with all of
these demons outside like trying to get
in
because that's pretty much the whole uh
story
and
can i also say
i mean there's so many great actors in
this the the cast of character actors in
this is just phenomenal
but
uh i have to say that billy zane steals
the [ __ ] show
man that dude right there
my ex-wife was gonna run off and [ __ ]
with that dude
whenever that guy was on some kind of
move you know her eyes would get all
kind of starry uh
[Laughter]
she was what she liked that movie
[ __ ] orlando she would watch orlando
just because it was mostly romance
scenes with [ __ ] billy zane or that i
didn't think
i actually liked that movie that was a
weird movie if i did see it i don't
remember it about an immortal that was
changing
sexes it was started off as a man then
she turned into a woman and then went
back to a man or whatever but she lived
like centuries she wasn't a human oh
okay i wasn't saying she it was a it was
whatever sex it wanted to be that sounds
kind of good i don't think i've seen
that yeah they never did explain it it's
just it started off like in the uh in
the middle ages i think is when the
story starts okay well i'm just gonna
i'm gonna have to put that that's pretty
sleek yeah you'd like that that's some
zane action him laying up in bed you're
[ __ ] with the sheets with the woman
and [ __ ] with his abs and [ __ ] with
his lips
she was always talking about his lips
and i'm looking i'm going is that i'm
thinking is that collagen i don't know i
think it is natural either it's growth
hormone that'll sometimes make a man's
lips
yeah they don't they don't look
unnaturally puffy to me um yeah he is a
good looking man
i kind of feel like well this was prior
great role he's great in this well this
was even prior to him doing titanic
because i feel like him being in titanic
and being kind of a villain sort of
character in that that sort of propelled
him to like super stardom so this was
like actually before that he plays satan
in this man that's how satan would yeah
or like a high up demon i guess because
they just call him the collector that's
what he's known as kind of kind of dude
that would like talk your wife into
doing porn
yeah yeah i think the be i mean there
are so many things to recommend this
movie um you know like i said it's just
a fun time and everybody in this
particularly billy zane looks like
they're having a [ __ ] blast
i mean he
just like i said everybody in this is
great but he really [ __ ] steals kind
of chews up the scenery a bit in a
couple scenes but in a good way in a
good way yeah he's he cuts loose
like i said he looks like he's having
like a [ __ ] fantastic time making
this yeah well they're making a horror
movie you know yeah he's just having a
good time everybody's everybody's having
a good time and that makes the audience
have a good time yeah also i really like
the kind of mythology they have behind
this you know what i mean like it
actually has an interesting story behind
it
story being uh your main character who's
played by william sadler
who
i knew it was like he's been in a
million things but he plays like a lot
of bad guys but he's actually kind of a
good guy in this although you don't
really know that at first he was uh he
played death in the bill and ted movie
that had death in it so so that was him
but he's been in a million other things
too
so he's running away from billy zane
uh in cars they're not running literally
but they're like chasing each other in
cars at night like across the desert i
guess it's new mexico right i don't know
i think it's new mexico
so they're chasing each other across and
then uh you know billy zane like
basically rams into his car and like
sets it on fire and then the cops come
and you know both of them are unharmed
which you know that seems a little weird
and then there's also the thing where
william sadler's character who's
actually named breaker but when he you
know at first he's just telling me he's
mr smith which you know his fake name
but he has like these little star things
like in his palm so you know he there's
some like some magical [ __ ] going on
like from pretty much from the beginning
because he's got these stars in there
and they kind of like move around like
little red dots and stuff
so he's trying to run away from billy
zane
you don't know why
he tries to steal a car but he gets
caught by this long-haired kid who looks
like the lost member of hansen
and so he like runs off but then he runs
into a drunk
played by dick miller who is in goddamn
every movie ever made holy [ __ ]
for sure every like horror movie i think
most people recognize him from gremlins
but he was in
jesus christ he's been in everything
going back to like the [ __ ] 60s man
he's the old dude that shows up he's
kind of like the voice of reason like
the man on the street yeah
he's your uncle or your grandpa that
shows up in the movie tries to [ __ ]
fix [ __ ] i love tells you what to do
every time dick miller's in a movie it's
just kind of like he's one of those
dudes that's like every time you see in
a movie it just makes me happy yeah you
know what i mean he's just that he's one
of those guys yeah he's almost a burgess
meredith but he's not classing the joint
up really he's [ __ ]
he's good though he's good but yeah he
always kind of plays he plays a lot of
like kind of grizzled old drunks or
bombs or something like that yeah which
[ __ ]
burgess meredith did that too so he was
kind of a burgess meredith kind of a guy
burgess was dead so you had to get
somebody they get this guy yeah dick
miller's dead now too yeah unfortunately
right but uh [ __ ] he lived a full life
that dude he did old dude making money
that's what i mean i think when i was
talking about um the original uh little
shop of horrors i think he was in the
original little shop of warriors
um you know so he's had a long and
varied career and like pretty much
i mean tons and tons of like b movies
horror movies and stuff like that he's
in all that he is always playing himself
though it's that same role at every and
i guess that's who he was yeah i mean
that's what he seems like he's like yeah
and he kind of was always standing in
for the voice of reason
come on you kids are crazy he's one of
those kind of guys you know but also you
gotta fight the demons he always comes
across as like a drunk though
even if he's not playing a drunk bomb in
the movie
it's your drunk bomb uncle
shows up who has that like street wisdom
yeah he's trying to get you incompetent
in grades the [ __ ]
the hell you guys doing and a lot of it
gives bad advice too sometimes
but that's just what it was yeah it's
kind of a comedic relief character or a
comfort character yeah i think it's kind
of a good way to put it
he plays yeah he plays a character named
uncle willy and then he's uncle willie
so i don't he's not anybody's uncle in
particular i don't think he's just nick
collins well he always played a generic
uncle yes
it was an uncle figure yeah
he's evonkular i really like that word
but uh yeah so he so uh so breaker
runs into dick miller uh dick miller is
kind of like oh well you know you can
because he says he needs a place to stay
he's like well you can come stay at this
boarding house uh you know where i live
and you know you can come there and get
away from this dude or whatever so they
go to this boarding house which he
points out used to be a decommissioned
church which will actually be kind of
significant later
so he goes into this church and as i
said it's kind of a it's a boarding
house hotel
so there's kind of a
group of people that live there
so you have like the woman that owns the
place who's played by cch pounder who
she was in a ton of stuff too like like
i said there's
character actors like out the [ __ ]
wazoo in this you will recognize every
single person in this
so she runs it there's a a prostitute
who lives there played by brenda becky
uh her name is cordelia i think and then
there's uh charles fleischer who
probably most famously voice of roger
rabbit he plays a postal worker who just
got fired who is also in love with the
prostitute so he lives up in the attic
and then there's uh jada pinkett is in
this too
and she's like she works there i guess
she's like on a work release program
and uh so she like cleans the sheets and
cooks and whatever and all that kind of
stuff and then
you have another guy who doesn't live
there but who is like the boyfriend of
the prostitute and his name is roach and
he's played by thomas hayden church so
like i said there's like the [ __ ]
cast this is amazing
so at first you're not entirely sure
like what the [ __ ] is going on with this
dude like i said william sadler comes in
he says my name is mr smith and
everybody's like yeah sure it is but
whatever
and he's very mysterious
and so then um
somebody says like oh he was the guy
that tried to steal you know the car
and so cch pounder's character she calls
the cops
the cops come and the cops have billy
zane with them
and so billy zane is trying to like
pretend that he's the good guy and he's
like oh this dude like stole an artifact
from me and i was just trying to get it
back
so
at first you'd think that maybe william
sadler is the bad guy because he tries
to like he pulls like jada pinkett and
he's like oh i'm gonna stab her if you
don't like let me go and all this other
kind of stuff and so they're trying to
like you know leave it ambiguous as to
whether he's a good guy or not but as it
turns out as we mentioned earlier uh
billy zane is actually a bad guy now for
a long time you don't really know
you know that there's something
supernatural going on because like i
said you've seen the thing like on the
dude's hand and it's like moving around
and stuff and
so you know that there's some kind of
something like that but they actually
kind of like leave it for a while before
it's explained what's going on but i
kind of like that because you sort of
get to hang out with these characters
and they kind of do like a good little
intro it's not a super long movie i
think it's only 93 minutes something
like that but they do a good job like
establishing each of these characters
and they're really interesting
characters so you don't mind like
hanging out with them
so it turns out that billy zane is
he's like the devil or he's like a high
up demon i guess like i said in the in
the thing he's just called the collector
so i guess he's just like
going collecting souls or whatever i
don't think he's the devil but he's
devil-like in the sense that he's trying
to tempt people
into like doing his bidding
so what he can do is he cuts open his
hand and like all this green blood comes
out and then it sprouts all these demons
out of the ground
so
after that point it becomes essentially
like i said a siege movie where you're
just kind of like all these people are
trapped in this hotel
and they're trying to keep the demons
from getting in or like the demons from
like possessing them one of the best
scenes in this like when they first sort
of established that this is absolutely
that not only is billy's ain't a bad guy
but he's also like supernatural is when
one of the cops like tries to arrest him
and billy just like turns around and
straight up just punches right through
his head yeah that's good and then pulls
his head off
i wanted to do that before
yeah i think we all have imagine it bam
it doesn't actually
in work life in real life just protest
yeah
just right through that dudes just pow
right through a cop's head and i was
just kind of like i had forgotten that
scene and when they did it i was just
like i laughed and laughed and laughed
because that's so [ __ ] great the gore
in this is great he's trying to shake
him loose from his fist yeah and he's
like damn it and you're trying to get
him out pretty good that's what happens
when you punch through someone's head
like that and then it just gets stuck on
your head yeah there's a certain tone to
the violence it's it is gory but it's
kind of humorous at the same time it's
not it's not a very mean-spirited
gore-fest
no not at all i don't like saw or
anything yeah it's that's why this movie
is real kind of like fun which you know
the original tales from the crypt series
was also fun it's horror comedy yeah and
it was like over the top same kind of
tone as evil dead i would probably say
yeah it's just like a really fun yeah
it's like it's very splattery yes
there's like lots of you know and yeah
the demon effects do kind of recall
evil dead like when some of the people
start getting possessed and uh by demons
and whatnot like they have like the big
jaws like with the you know and their
eyes glow and all this other kind of
stuff so it looks like really good you
got some full body
demon outfits that look really good
especially because they got the damn
extended feet that they walk on walking
tiptoes like werewolves
you i i know that it's it's basically a
pair of
high heels without heels on the back of
it but it looks good they were going
upstairs they actually show walking
upstairs with it some of them look like
men and some of them look like women in
those costumes but it's just
real skinny
yeah i'm assuming they got dancers
that's what they usually do like for for
that type of thing so they can have
somebody that moves around like that the
costumes and the practical effects are
good real good yeah for something as low
budget as this uh yeah i have to say the
practical effects look pretty fantastic
it was a great mix they didn't do any cg
monsters or any [ __ ] they just did
cg magical effects when people putting
up a magical
damn protection spell over the doorway
type of deal
and it and then but then the demons are
practical effects and the gore is
practical and just the tone the way it
was just
it looked just right it's perfect yeah i
mean like i said like we were mentioning
before there there is some cgi in the
sense that to destroy the demons you
have to like uh
basically either shoot them or stab them
or whatever in the eyes yeah and if you
do that like a bunch of green lightning
like comes out yeah so there's that
that's cgi obviously and the uh artifact
that um that william sadler had i keep
calling him by his
breaker is his character's name i keep
calling by the actor's name but the uh
the kind of key cross situation like
artifact that he has if you it has blood
inside it and if you dump the blood like
a little bit on the window frame or the
door frame it makes like a protection so
the demons can't get in the way they
handled the cgi effects
looked classical it didn't look like it
looked like classic effects yeah like it
didn't look like cgi it looked like a
real high-end version of the effects
you'd see like in big trouble in little
china
which is kind of like a classical
steven spielberg style effects but these
look a lot more 3d they just look better
you know
so yeah it's a cg effect but it looks
like a classical effect
like yeah some from the 70s but much
better much better look good yeah i
thought they did a really nice job like
with the special effects on this but
like i said that was kind of
i i like the way this actually even
though it's not your standard like
morality story or [ __ ] gets their
comeuppance story like like most of the
ec comics tales from the crypt ones were
um so they did something a little bit
different but this does
seem very much like an hour and a half
long episode of the show yeah but with a
little bit extra you know what i mean it
has the tone is very similar you know
it's funny it's over the top it's gory
there's titties
it's it's muddy it has like a lot of uh
raunchy humor
like like i said like the original show
did showcases a lot of nice racks
yeah the one scene in particular where
uncle willie dick miller's character
yeah when he gets tempted
by the devil by billy zane yeah uh it's
basically like this big huge like
outdoor bar with a bunch of topless
women yeah that's his version of trying
to get him to draw because he's like an
alcoholic so they're trying to like get
him to like guarantee yeah it's like
beer and titties yeah and then it's
funny too because then they have billy
zane because he kind of changes
character depending on who he's trying
to tempt yeah and in this one uh and
i've seen a couple other reviewers like
point this out that he looked kind of
like and sounded kind of like hunter s
thompson yeah
i think that's who he was trying with
this with the little pipe and then
the glasses and the way he's talking
yeah
that must have been his hero hunter s
thompson yeah so that's how you came at
it man that made a lot of sense yeah
yeah yeah but that's i mean that's it's
like super funny but like i said it
depends on because i really like the one
scene it's actually kind of creepy when
he seduces uh or he tries to tempt
cordelia where he doesn't try to he does
actually um and he he's trying to get
somebody to let him in because like i
said they've put protection spells or
all the doors all the demons can't get
in but he's just standing there and like
psychically talking to her through the
window telling it's you know i
understand you i know that you didn't
have to become a pro you only became a
prostitute because you were looking for
someone to love you and all this other
stuff and she like actually kind of like
falls for it
and ends up getting possessed and not
only killing uh charles fleischer's
character uh by eating his heart out i
think but she also like rub like rips
off cch pounder's arm which is funny
because so she gets her arm ripped off
and it's pretty [ __ ] up for a while
because she looks like she might die and
[ __ ] like that but they put something on
it or a tourniquet or whatever and then
she drinks some vodka and then she
actually goes on to do like some kind of
badass [ __ ] like even without an arm and
i was like wow hardcore i just like i
like that scene where she's doesn't have
an arm and then billy zane like tries to
tempt her and she like holds her stump
up like that and he's like are you
saying yes or are you like taking your
arm back and she's like no i'm flicking
you off but like you can't see it
because she doesn't have arm it gets
like pulled off right there it's like
super funny
but uh yeah so what the story behind
this is it's weird because it's almost
like a biblical story
what it is is the the artifact
um you know he breaker tells the story
that you know before god created the
earth or the universe or whatever uh you
know when the darkness in the void and
all that that was like full of demons
and the demons had seven keys that sort
of like were trying to like focusing
their power or something like that
so um when god came and made light it
scattered all the keys like around and
the demons sort of like scattered to
wherever
and uh but they've been trying to
collect all the keys so they can like
take over again and like make everything
darkness again so this key is the last
one
so originally the key had jesus's blood
in it
but
as the as the millennia have gone on
whoever is the guardian of the key like
they live for however long
and then you know when the next guardian
comes along that's it's on their hand
like it'll be the signal oh this is
where you got to go like the net to do
the next guardian and then they'll have
to die and then the next guardian will
put their blood in it and their blood
will protect again so it's like a really
cool mythology that they came up with
for the for the backstory you think they
would have uh
continued with that that you could make
a whole series based on that
you definitely could i'm just like what
and it's kind of a shame that
i mean the thing about it as i said
originally this was going to be like the
tales from the krypton was going to be
like a trilogy which like i said it kind
of was because they did make three they
made this they made bordello of blood
and then they made ritual which like i
said didn't get a theatrical release but
they didn't really didn't stick with
that no and it will and they weren't
sequels it was supposed to be
i mean the the key was supposed to be in
all three of them the key was in
bordello of blood although it wasn't a
main like plot point i think it was just
kind of like an easter egg type thing uh
but i don't think it was in ritual it's
been a while since i've seen that
but i kind of feel like
you know what i y since anthology tv
particularly horror anthology tv has
made such a comeback yeah you could do
this i kind of feel like you know creep
show made a comeback like on shutter and
it's like all these
yeah evil dead like you know american
horror story which i think is still
going like all that kind of stuff and i
kind of feel like you know all the you
know mike flanagan stuff that they do on
netflix it's like you could totally
reboot this
nowadays um tales from the crypt and but
as long as you have that same fun kind
of like what they did with creep show
where it was because tales from the
crypt i feel like even more than creep
show even though they're both kind of
based on easy comics
tales from the crypt the hbo series
their big thing was over the top gore
over-the-top smut
and
puns
so you would really have to capture that
same
vibe it was supposed to be like really
over the top and really illicit because
it was one of the few
you know back when it started in 1989
you know they there was a lot of gory
movies and stuff like that but you
didn't really see any horror gore stuff
like that like on tv
so it was kind of groundbreaking in a
way that hbo was doing it so they were
completely taking advantage of the fact
that you know they didn't have sponsors
they could show whatever they wanted so
they went like really really gory and
really smutty with it and a lot of
people really really dug it and like i
said it was they got like a lot of big
actors and a lot of big directors to
like work on it over the seven years and
it's kind of a shame that
i mean it's kind of a shame that they
waited so long to do
movie versions because by the time this
came out it was supposed to come out in
halloween on halloween of 1994 but then
it got pushed back to january of 1995
which you know january for a long time
has been like the dump month that's kind
of where they just put the stuff they
don't know where else to stick it and so
it came out it did okay like i think it
made about twice its budget back but no
more than that got kind of mixed reviews
although it's gotten uh you know a cult
following um now but
i just kind of feel like
see the hbo show
it only ran until 1996. so it only ran
like for another few months like after
this came out and then bordello of blood
the movie came out i think like 18
months after this and didn't do very
well at all and a lot of people i i kind
of like that movie but this one's better
bordello of blood
i saw it again recently and i think
shutter just added it because shutter
just added this one as well um
bordello of blood suffers i think from
having dennis miller
[Laughter]
i mean dennis miller
his shtick in you know like in the late
80s and early 90s was kind of funny yeah
but
when you see it now it just didn't age
well it's really really
really uh
annoying yeah and uh it's not too bad
actually breaking the mood yeah it's not
too bad in bordeaux blood he did kind of
tone it down a little bit but that's so
that that snarky sorry it's just like i
don't it just doesn't work for me yeah
um even though like i said back at back
in the day i kind of thought he was
funny but i was like that with bill
murray some of bill murray's movies just
couldn't that couldn't stand that
[ __ ] snarky [ __ ] it was great in
[ __ ] um
uh ghostbusters the ghostbusters series
i like that but some of that [ __ ] is
terrible although his recent [ __ ] was
really good but we remembered he was in
a zombie movie with [ __ ] uh yeah uh
dude who played [ __ ]
darth [ __ ] out of driver item driver
wasn't him that movie the zombie movie
the reason the dead don't die the dead
how do you remember these damn titles
from these obscure movies dead don't die
uh
murray was good at that i remember lots
of things yeah murray was good in that
well you should have seen well he was in
the first zombie land too and he's
[ __ ] great in that yeah he was kind
of it was kind of like a glorified cameo
yeah but what a [ __ ] cameo it was i
have to say
but yeah so the nice thing about this
one
about demon knight is that it just has a
really really solid
cast of character actors they all look
like they're having a blast um you know
nobody phoned it in nobody is like oh
what the [ __ ] am i doing in this tales
from the crypt movie uh they really went
whole hog with uh the special effects
with the demon makeup although you know
what when they were first like talking
about this universal pictures was like
well maybe we should do two versions in
case we can't afford to do all the demon
makeup so they did another version they
didn't shoot it but they had another
version like on the back burner
that it was still gonna be kinda demons
but they weren't gonna look like demons
they were actually gonna look like
billy zane was gonna be like a bible
salesman and all the demons were just
gonna look like men in black essentially
like they were just gonna look like guys
with sunglasses and black suits on so
they had that on the back burner they
said well it's just in case we can't
afford to do the over-the-top demon
makeup but i guess they decided
thankfully that they were gonna go the
whole hog demon route and i'm really
glad they did because the demons in this
look pretty great have to say too that
the long-haired hanson kid
who uh you know who caught breaker like
trying to bust into a car at the
beginning
i love too that this movie also kills
that [ __ ] kid off and the kid's not
annoying you know like kids and movies
tend to be he wasn't even in it that
much he was just into the beginning a
little bit and then like they find him
again at the end like his parents got
turned into demons and then he gets
turned into a demon
and
then he basically gets thrown out a
window and explodes
like the kid explains because they like
shoot him a thing and then his like
little converse or whatever like falls
down on the ground and i'm like awesome
yeah i love when they blow up kids in
movies uh also soundtrack for this
not too bad this had a lot of i mean
it's very 90s
uh this even opens with that song uh hey
man nice shot that filter song uh which
was kind of all the rage in the mid 90s
and this had uh who else was on this
ministry pantera megadeth yeah um
yeah a lot of the music isn't actually
in the movie except like on the end
credits and stuff but
the uh the soundtrack i think did pretty
okay and honestly i just saw
a thing uh on a website that's selling
uh i guess it's a reissue of this
soundtrack and it's on clear vinyl with
like green swirls all in it it's pretty
cool actually yeah um because i can
energy yeah i like i could see how like
some people would that were really into
90s uh like industrial and stuff like
that would kind of want this because you
know in metal and stuff because there's
a lot a lot of like pretty decent [ __ ]
on there
i think rollins band was on there too if
i'm not mistaken but yeah so
i mean if you were at all a fan of tales
from the crips the original hbo show uh
i can't see that you wouldn't like this
it's not exactly the same story formula
but they did something that was similar
enough to the show but also different
enough
you know that they're like oh it's like
a movie experience but it still has all
the stuff that you love about the show
and it's just kind of a shame that they
didn't
i like i said i feel like they waited
too long to do it they should have
started making movies
when
the tales from the crypts show was still
in the middle of its run they shouldn't
have waited until it was like had
already been going for six or seven
seasons and oh and now we're gonna make
a movie because i kind of feel like
maybe the interest had waned some
um
you know but you could totally reboot
this nowadays and i think they probably
should they don't have to remake this
movie but i like the idea of doing like
an anthology type movie that's based on
like tales from the crypt they could
even like base the [ __ ] on some of the
original like ec
stories like from the comics that would
be really cool like you could modern
modernize them and update them i would
totally watch it
get on that [ __ ] shutter or netflix or
whoever well i just have to agree i
think it's a classic movie
has a real classic 80s slash 90s style
american horror
horror comedy you know in the vein of
evil dead you know like that yeah a lot
of fun
um
yeah and it's tight music was good you
know the score was good special effects
great
acting was good just had a real good
tone real good energy behind the movie
and uh aged very well so you could watch
that today you'd have a great time
yeah i mean i had a great time
re-watching this and as i said like
billy zayn everybody's great in this but
billy zane is absolutely
fantastic very entertaining so so
entertaining the visuals are very
artistic high quality it's a high-end
movie and like i said you know a little
about kids
so yeah you can't you can't beat that
and lots of boobies yeah yeah
without saying how can you go wrong you
can't so yeah if you have shutter uh
shutter just added this i believe they
also added bordello blood uh they also
added some other anthology stuff like
tails from the hood and tails from the
hood too like they usually they usually
add um you know like groups of similar
type of things you know i mean like
we're gonna add like all the universal
monster movies we're gonna add like a
bunch of horror anthologies we're gonna
do this so i think that's really cool so
uh so this one was added along with uh
several other ones of a similar nature
so if you have shutter uh you should
absolutely go watch it i'm sure you can
find out other streaming services as
well
uh but yeah if you have seen it let us
know what you think about it in the
comments and that will do it for this
movie retrospective we will see you guys
on the next one bye
you